Oh Heather thank you for joining us from
New York from the Big Apple thank you
this is a lot of this is gonna be a lot
of fun a first Skype session all right
so yeah Heather let walk us walk us
through all this Manhattan Institute is
a really cool think-tank it's constantly
been rated in the top think tanks how
long have you been involved with them
about 92 I started writing for their
quarterly magazine called City Journal
and since then have been a regular
contributor to their publication and and
have been joined living through the
transformation of New York City in its
glory years in 1990 with Mayor Rudolph
Guiliani the Manhattan Institute played
a big role in serving as kind of a think
tank for his ideas so that was that was
an exciting time ideas that really
resonated with New York and with you
I'm sorry she said which were some of
the ideas that work well certainly the
notion that crime is in fact not a
permanent condition of American cities
that policing contrary to what was then
received wisdom can be very effective in
bringing Public Safety to high crime
neighborhoods and that one important
factor of successful policing is paying
attention to public disorder something
that has been long lost in San Francisco
Civic culture but the police started
listening to the demands that come
constantly from law-abiding residents of
of high crime neighborhoods to get the
drug dealers off the corners to get the
kids that are hanging out in hundreds
fighting on the corners away so that
elderly ladies can get to the store
without worrying about getting caught in
a fight and certainly the vagrancy and
homeless problems were for once paid
attention to turnstile jumping was no
longer ignored and so slowly but surely
the sense of anarchy and threat that had
taken over New York City in the early
1990s lifted and you got an
extraordinary economic transformation of
the city that was driven by the fact
that our crime rate started plummeting
so the idea of crime not being a
necessity in society something that can
be overturned with things like education
better parenting better communities what
was kind of your discovery about that
well there's two narratives you know the
the liberal narrative about crime was
that you couldn't solve it without
eradicating its alleged root causes
which were traditionally said to be
income inequality poverty and race
ism and so the solution to high crime
was a lot more government spending and
redistribution and social programs the
conservative analysis of crime one that
I agree with is that it grows
overwhelmingly out of family breakdown
when you have a culture like you have in
many inner cities now where there's
virtually no expectation that young boys
should marry the mother of the children
that they are spreading around the
neighborhood they don't have young boys
don't have any incentive to develop the
bourgeois values that would make them
attractive mates marriage civilize as
men not always obviously but on average
it is in the extraordinarily important
cultural value well the interesting
thing about New York City in the 1990s
is not at the liberal nor the
conservative root causes of crime
changed very much the traditional
liberal analysis of neighborhoods of we
didn't get a lot more social spending
there there wasn't a huge reduction in
income inequality nor did we see a drop
in out of wedlock child rearing in
neighborhoods like Central Harlem or
central Brooklyn or the South Bronx what
changed was the quality of policing it
became data-driven accountable and
proactive and that was the discovery
that fulfilled a promise that Mayor
Rudolph Giuliani and his first Police
Commissioner William Bratton made to the
city that through data-driven
accountable policing they would finally
bring the public safety to high crime
neighborhoods that they have an absolute
right to expect and I will say what you
know another another conventional
explanation is that you cannot lower
crime
until you have an economic turnaround
that's the William Julius Wilson
explanation for high crime neighborhoods
is the jobs all left and therefore
social breakdown accelerated and crime
accelerated in fact in many cases it's
the reverse causation that is important
you cannot have an economic revival in
high crime neighborhoods when crime is
as high as it can be employers only the
most marginal employers are going to
move into a neighborhood when they have
to worry that their employees are going
to get mugged coming to work in the
morning or leaving work at night so what
we saw in New York was by driving crime
down that is what spurred the economic
revival on 125th Street in Harlem in
parts of Brooklyn that now have been
massively gentrified because people
could go to restaurants at night without
fear of getting mugged and people could
take their children to school without
fear that they would get shot yeah what
were some of those data-driven processes
that we looked at to figure out how to
reduce crime what was going on well New
York the New York Police Department
developed I think the most
groundbreaking government revolution of
the last quarter century it's come to be
known as CompStat and this is a process
that has been picked up in other areas
of governments across the country but it
began with weekly meetings at police
headquarters where the top brass that
worked downtown in them in the police
headquarters would on a weekly basis
call in a precinct commander a district
commander that I don't know you know
these are called different things but
the the guy who had geographic
responsibilities for a particular part
of New York City and the precinct
commander would be called downtown and
some
checked into an extraordinarily high
tension high-powered meeting where the
top brass would grill him about crime
patterns on his watch they have would
have spent the previous week or month
analyzing going out to the precinct
doing their own sort of shoe-leather
reporting on what was going on in those
precincts poring over the precincts
crime data they called the commander and
grill him about his knowledge of
patterns and merging crime patterns and
whether he had a strategy for quelling
if there'd been an outbreak say of
burglaries on a particular thoroughfare
or robberies of elderly women on a
particular street this was this
expectation that the commander was
responsible for crime had never been
lodged against a precinct commanders
before and these initial ComStat
meetings were so high-powered and high
tension that sometimes chairs were
thrown people were known to throw up
before they got on the hot seat because
the pressure on them was so unrelenting
to finally bring the homicide rate down
in 2000 1990 New York's homicide numbers
reached two thousand and two hundred and
forty five and the sense of urgency that
the New York Police Department had under
Mayor rule of Giuliani and Bratton to
bring the crime rate down was enormous
and the CompStat process which continues
to this day and is a a system for
sharing information the the city the
department started gathering data on
first a daily basis about crime that on
an hourly basis and a minute-by-minute
basis using increasingly sophisticated
computer techniques to analyze the
patterns of crime and try to figure out
what strategies were working this
brought the data revolution into the
NYPD
made it agile and again data-driven and
this type of accountability and
information sharing process has been
picked up in other government agencies
to hold managers responsible and and
make sure that the agency is using as
much up-to-date information to develop
and and follow up on its strategies as
it possibly can and keeping
neighborhoods safe that way and we were
talking about this when we were at
Berkeley together I had mentioned to you
Palantir software with data fusion
technology and that seems like it's
another step in the future taking in all
of the new social media information of
the phone records all of that kind of
data that can predict crime and then be
at the right place at the right time to
prevent homicide that that bet seems to
be so important for kids safety all that
kind of stuff for securing our future
did that seems to be the direction of
which we're going you think no
absolutely a Palantir and other
so-called predictive policing
methodologies are really just a
beefed-up version of ComStat because
ComStat was doing the same thing it
would you know the meanings they throw
on the PowerPoint screen the data points
of where crime is happening and try to
bring local knowledge to bear on where
it's likely to break out next the
challenge is of course that these
predictive policing technologies have
been challenged on the ground that they
somehow reproduce what I think is
phantom police racism by showing yet
again that the overwhelming majority of
violent street crime is committed in
minority neighborhoods the false
narrative that we've been living with
for the past five five years are really
30 years about policing
is that it is pervaded with systemic and
lethal bias if that's the case if
somehow every police officer through
some mysterious process gets infected by
bias on his job you would think that the
solution would be to use computer
algorithms that are presumably free of
this scourge of implicit bias again I do
not acknowledge that that is a problem
but if it were a problem a impartial
computer algorithm should be the
solution except it turns out when you
have computers analyzing crime data and
making predictions about where it's
going to happen next they reach the
identical conclusions as human analysts
which is that the vast majority of
victimization is incurring in minority
neighborhoods and that's because the
vast majority of criminal commission is
also occurring there this kind of leads
us to talking about about behavior and
the differences in behavior you actually
we were chatting about this a little bit
right before we went live but it is so
true that kids that are born out of
wedlock typically have higher rates of
crime what what have you learned about
studying this what are these other
indicators about behavioral differences
for what happens to a kid when they're
really young and the seats planted in
their head and then their environment
and everything that's interacting with
them through their adulthood and what
how they end up either being in crime or
not being in crime would have
well the social science data is pretty
unequivocal that children raised in
single-parent homes are many times more
likely to drop out of school to fail in
school to get involved in juvenile
delinquency to have children as teens as
if they're females and that's not to say
I mean this is such a touchy subject it
should not be because our concern should
be looking at the data to finding out
what kids need but it's not to say that
there are not countless heroic single
mothers who are working overtime to
raise law-abiding children above all
young males and are succeeding against
the odds but the odds really are against
them for a variety of reasons and it's
it's amazing that we have sort of turned
this into such a puzzle or mystery after
thousands of years of how children have
been raised but on average children do
better with their mother and their
father if you want to look at it purely
from an economic point of view which i
think is the least relevant children
raised in single-parent households are
five times more likely to be poor than
children raised with two married parents
and that's because you have the double
earning power but it's the economics of
it are the least relevant as far as I'm
concerned you have two sets of kin you
have somebody when the child has been
throwing a tantrum for the last three
hours another parent that can provide
relief you have complimentary on average
parenting styles between mothers and
fathers again it's not to say that
they're not instances where it is the
mother that is the disciplinarian that
tells the child to suck it up and you
know get over it and just go on and it's
the father who is much more
sympathetic and and compassionate or
vulnerable to the you know the feeling
the child's pain but on average males
and females are different they're
different psychologically they're
different biologically this is again
we're speaking averages and children do
best with both their parents and what
you find is not only on an individual
basis but when you have a culture where
marriage has disappeared as the norm as
I said earlier boys are not raised with
a particular cultural script which says
you don't go around serially
impregnating girls you wait
ideally until you're ready to get
married or to be a a breadwinner and
without that expectation what you have
now in many inner-city neighborhoods is
something which social science rather
awkwardly calls multi partner fertility
where any given female has children by
several different males
and every given male has children by
several different females that is a
chaotic situation for children even if
those fathers wanted to or try to
somehow provide absentee father child
support for their many children it
becomes incredibly complicated and
traumatic for children I write about in
my book some of these young crack
dealers who themselves are acutely aware
of the fact that they needed their
fathers they they have a scale of four
paternal involvement one one boy that I
write about says that he's come out of
it pretty well because he's only a crack
dealer because his father came around
every so often when he was a child
whereas his brother who the mother
refers
with pride as a stone-cold gangster and
who specializes in armed robbery his
father never showed up and so the young
crack dealer attributes this to the fact
that he the crack dealer did have an
occasional father in his life whereas
his younger brother Reggie was raised
exclusively by the crack addicted mother
there's that's how so much to unpack
Heather that's really interesting and I
think so many that are tuning in will
just light up with realization that it
makes complete sense not only is someone
a young child going to be more inclined
especially involved in crime to not care
so much about breadwinning and caring
about building a career and caring about
going out and about to go into a
relationship with one person and have
two children with one person but that
creates a hugely chaotic situation for
both men and women getting impregnated
at young ages with multiple partners all
that kind of stuff and then furthermore
like you said for the the stress levels
for one partner to be able to handle
raising a child through their tantrums
and through all the ups and downs is
crazy compared to - it's just a less
stressful experience more harmonious
more people get some more sleep
things like that so this is really
interesting and so then this sort of the
racial like inequalities between this
what have you learned in that field and
then we'll kind of get into like the
mismatch effect as well after that but
yeah why don't you tell us about that
well let's let's give some historical
perspective here in 1965 Senator Daniel
Patrick Moynihan when he was at that
point working for Lyndon Johnson and
they were working on civil rights
remedies and trying to figure out a way
to alleviate inner-city poverty
when Moynihan was in the Labor
Department he did a study that of inner
city life that said that the fact that
the black family was breaking down to
the extent it was was going to put a
roadblock in the achievement of future
raychel equality he warned against what
happens to communities when marriage
goes away at that point what daniel
patrick moynihan viewed as a
catastrophic level of out of wedlock
child rearing in the black community was
a twenty three percent rate of black
children being born to single mothers
the white rate at that point was in the
low single digits today nationally the
rate of black children born to single
mothers is 71 percent three times what
Moynihan viewed as a cataclysmic social
situation and if you go to certain dense
inner-city neighborhoods like Milwaukee
or the Mott Haven in the Bronx West Side
south side of Chicago you're going to
find out of wedlock birth rates up
closer to 80 and 85 percent the white
rate at this point is about 26%
nationally we're reaching a way over 40
percent when you average everybody in
it's extremely worrisome and unless this
gets turned around I think that again as
Moynihan said we are cannot possibly
expect to have racial equality there's
no amount of government social service
programs and no amount of government
checks that can compensate for the lack
of a daily presence of a father in a
child's home and again you know I know
all of the objections of course if a
father is violent and is abusing among
divorce is a better situation than a
child having to witness the trauma of
that sort of sexual abuse and domestic
violence but those are outlying
situations what we have lost today is
the ability to say that on average
fathers and mothers are equally
important and that's because feminism
has taught us to believe that strong
women can do it all and men are being
systemically marginalized in our culture
today demeaned
you know viewed as the source of white
males in particular the source of all
evil in the world and so it becomes very
hard to rehabilitate fathers in that
sort of environment I cannot begin to
wrap my mind is is really 40% of all
children are born out of English to a
single parent we're not born but are
being raised in a single-parent
household nationally yes and it's the
the white out of wedlock birth rate is
going up in the lower class
working-class environments that's what's
the topic of Charles Murray's recent
book coming apart where he looked at
these white working-class communities
that are ravaged by drugs and they are
starting to adopt the lifestyle of the
urban inner-city as far as single
parenting teen pregnancy and lack of
work attachment what is your what has
been your your gut and your analysis of
how people can take on more
responsibility for their actions
what is it is is the route bringing the
community more closer together through
early education about these types of
things in psyche and psychology
counseling what do we really need to do
to get this back to the drop from you
know 70% in in black single parent being
raising a children and forty percent
nationwide how do we get those numbers
down and build better communities what
do you think about that personal
responsibility side of things well I
think it's primarily a rhetorical issue
it's an ideological issue nobody
we are very reluctant as a culture now
to stigmatize anybody and there's a
understandable reason for that because
we now believe in individual freedom
were reluctant to the phrase that
developed in the 1960s blame-the-victim
we can see in the past that there were
instances perhaps of societies being
cruel to people that did not conform
nevertheless we used to have a norm that
said that people that are having
children out of wedlock are making very
poor moral choices and those females
were frankly stigmatized and today the
only stigma that the culture of the
elite culture is is willing to put on as
is say on especially on white males for
simply by virtue of being a white male
which is now said to carry with it an
entire baggage of oppression but I would
say even if we're not willing to
stigmatize single mothers again which is
again in an individual instance stigma
can seem cruel and am 19th century
literature is filled with stories of you
know the cruel petty local village
driving out
wayward women say and again we're not
going to go back to that nor should we
but we have to be able to recognize that
there are better and worse environments
for raising children and I would like to
see a campaign to valorize fathers I am
sick of the constant you go girls you
know strong women can do it all rhetoric
we have a culture now that is
obsessively focused on trying to do
female uplift when in fact as is well
known by now females are the vast
majority of college students they're
graduating in higher rates and yet you
still have these massive liberal
foundations like Rockefeller and Ford
pumping out one female exclusive girl
exclusive program after another to try
and get more Latinas in the stem field
saying because nobody wants to talk
about boys or males because they're
basically persona non grata so I don't
think that there's social programs that
can solve this thing I think it takes a
mindset change to be willing to once
again valorized males yeah it's that
you're nailing it right there it's
important to bring back some sort of
conversation amongst all of us about
getting mmm
the stigma out of male development and
male involvement with bettering the
collective and not being stigmatized to
someone that's just greedy and all that
kind of stuff I'm really happy you
bringing that up that that leads us
right into talking about the admissions
and with what you've been studying with
the mich mismatch effect can you teach
us about that well the mismatch effect
is a concept that was first brought into
kind of scholarly attention by a UCLA
law professor named Richard sander
and it holds that preferences whether
it's gender preferences or racial
preferences but he's looked primarily at
racial preferences because they're so
ubiquitous when you're talking about
academic environments giving somebody a
racial preference does not do that
person any favor because you're your
catapulting the so called beneficiaries
and preferences into academic
environments where they're less
competitive with their peers and as a
result they have a hard time keeping up
and they don't learn as much in
classrooms if I were admitted to MIT say
and let's say I have 650 on my math SATs
but MIT had decided that gee we need
more females in stem it must mean if we
don't have females in stem it must be
because we're somehow discriminating
against all those great female
applicants that we're getting and not
admitting so if they admitted me in the
615 math SAT when all of my peers were
scoring 800 or close to 800 I would have
an almost impossible time keeping up in
my freshman year calculus or advanced
calculus class because the teaching
would be pitched to the average student
in my class which is not me it would be
to students who have mastered probably
advanced calculus or further math degree
fields and I would be left behind and as
a result I would learn less and I would
likely drop out of a stem major and
transfer into a less rigorous social
science and Humanities field and that's
what we see with the beneficial called
beneficiaries of racial preferences
there was an interesting study that was
done in Duke University
that found that black male students
actually entered Duke with a desire to
major in stem
the science technology engineering and
math fields that is higher than white
males but their attrition rate from the
STEM fields is enormous and by the time
any given class graduates there are very
few black males left in the sciences and
it's those Sciences are dominated by
white males and Asian males now if those
same black students and the reason is
because the black students have been
admitted with SAT scores that are well
over one standard deviation below what
the norm is for that school if those
students who've been admitted with
racial preferences to do instead went to
say North Carolina University and were
in classes where they matched their
fellow classmates in their academic
preparation level they would most likely
persist in a science degree and graduate
with it so racial preferences and and
what's amazing is the refusal of
colleges who inevitably have implemented
massive racial preferences the incoming
academic achievement gap has been 200
points on the 1600 point sats scale now
for decades again it varies from it's
about a standard deviation in in
academic qualifications but the schools
refused to be transparent about the data
I've written about this today in the
Wall Street Journal a case of a law
professor there Amy wax who has spoken
about the mismatch effect on a blogging
heads video with Glenn Lowry and spoke
frankly about the fact that at Penn as
in other law schools all
any any elite law school in the country
or selected law school in the country
practices massive racial preferences the
black students end up at the rock bottom
of their classes and again it's because
they have been put into environments for
which they are less able to compete it
is not fair to them and it also ends up
reinforcing whatever stereotypes people
might have about different academic
abilities that seems like meritocracy
that's not actually meritocracy and it
seems like a very bad social experiment
to run to see what would happen if you
threw a 650 math score SAT with an 800
but I must ask this question what if we
throw someone with a 780 in with the
eight hundreds and they are from Kenya
or Laos or Nigeria and they're able to
provide a very different more creative
aspect to the math and the engineers
around them is that a potential
possibility could that be something
beneficial could that be a good part of
this experiment to run well that's a red
herring you know that's always sort of
the hope that it's just a mere thumb on
the scale and that you have people that
it's a affirmative action as tiebreaker
idea that well if you let's say imagine
two equally qualified a white student a
black student who are you going to admit
in that case you're not harming the if
you if you want to choose a black
student that's fine with me but we are
not talking about a 780 and an 800 we
are talking again about massive
differences there's very few schools and
what you have is a cascading effect
Harvard can vacuum up every black
student that is remotely within the
average of the white and Asian scores it
gets them all and the next tear down has
to dip deeper into the pool of black
applicants in order to pursue it's
completely
I think irrelevant goal of diversity I
would completely disagree with you that
there is a Nigerian way of doing math or
chemistry that's ridiculous
the only thing that matters is your
ability to succeed in the current
climate college environment you're in as
a me wax said in her now highly
controversial video with Glenn Lowry no
one is saying that any given racial
group should not go to college if
somebody is is adequately prepared for a
college career of course go to college
but go to college with somebody that
you're prepared for the idea that racial
skin color diversity provides something
that is significant in scholarly
pursuits I simply disagree and we
produced now this is a perverse
situation where one of the frequent
complaints you hear from black students
whether it's a in a college class or a
law school when they're discussing
Constitutional History say our
constitutional law the black student
will complain well there we are
discussing the Fourteenth Amendment and
everybody looks to me for my opinion you
know and and the student is insulted by
that but that is precisely the rationale
of diversity that somehow by being black
you have some special insight to these
matters well you can't have it both ways
you can't
whether hether question so so maybe
you're you know you're totally right
about you know calculus and chemistry
that's you know that's definitely some
objective science and that that makes
total sense in terms of maybe like
spirituality and in terms
maybe culture relationship with family
and relationship with community you know
we're talking about that for looping all
the way back to the beginning of our
conversation with what's going on with
40% of children being raised by only one
child a parent in the United States
isn't that also potentially something
that we could learn from a different
part of the world is maybe how to be
more a part of the community maybe that
person that is coming in from across the
world can bring that sort of diversity
of thought to the table that could
potentially be something insightful do
you agree well if you're coming from a
school that's a definition I don't know
if you think that children of single
parents but yeah all else being equal
you can strive for diversity of
experience or family background or
culture by all means and colleges give
themselves enormous airs about they're
highly creative and artistic efforts to
assemble these somehow works of art
classes I think it's rather phony
because they pay fanatical attention to
SAT scores to the 0.00001% when they're
deciding among whites and Asians and
then suddenly declare that they're
irrelevant when it comes to
underrepresented minorities but fine if
you want to focus on either skin color
or gonads in assembling your class by
all means do so but the thing that has
to come first is whether you're bringing
in students that are prepared to compete
because if you don't you were subjecting
them to psychological stress you know a
lot of these protests that we've been
hearing from the last several years on
campuses the black lives matter protest
when you have things like Princeton's
black Princeton students claiming to be
oppressed on campus which is absurd they
are the most privileged individuals in
human history
but part of that sense of being racially
oppressed in an environment that is
tolerant and compassionate and
open-minded is because precisely of
mismatch that if you find yourself
struggling to compete
you can either explain that by virtue of
the fact that you were not adequately
prepared or you can say I must be
experiencing institutional racism I
don't you know is is now quickly is you
you're totally right you they need to be
able to compete at the really high
levels and we'd be subjecting people to
a lot of psychological stress if they're
unable to do so you mentioned this is
something that I just I feel like people
will want to know or the reason why you
said this how exactly are the people
behind the black lives matter are they
the most privileged people what I said
was that any college student today is
among the most privileged individuals in
human history
I do not buy the idea that we hear from
college any college student today yeah
any couple
oh okay any caution today okay yeah yeah
definitely I mean so much ubiquity in
water and food and electricity and all
this great stuff their education that's
being delivered to them with technology
and everything so maybe let's let's chat
about this new book new book coming out
diversity delusion coming out in the
fall give us a little taste as much as
he can well it continues to a certain
step we've just been talking about
colleges have now been taken over by a
single idea which is diversity it
determines the curriculum it you cannot
have a college administrator open his
mouth without within say five seconds
the word diversity coming out there are
massive campus bureaucracies dedicated
to the Fantom the preposterous
delusional idea that college campuses
today are rife with racism so you have
Vice chance
of equity diversity and inclusion being
creative right left the Vice Chancellor
of equity diversity and inclusion at the
University of California LA UCLA is
pulling in four hundred and forty four
thousand dollars a year that's just a
tip of the diversity iceberg at any
given college this at a time when
colleges are of course claiming penury
possibly raising tuition and I think
that this is a a complete sideshow that
the focus of college should be on
learning but teaching students of an
ever number growing group of alleged
victim groups to think of themselves as
victims does them no favor to to spell
out the privileges to be on college
campuses today you have at your
fingertips
the thing that Faust sold his soul for
which is knowledge you can get access to
every single book that has ever been
written whether it's through technology
or your own college library
you have scientific laboratories
available you can learn languages you
can study history you can wallow in
beauty whether it's kept low or
Aeschylus or Shakespeare or Wordsworth
or or Jane Austen all of that is
available to you you were surrounded by
well-meaning adults who want the best
for all of their students and yet you
have these amazing campus protests
encouraged by the diversity bureaucracy
where students are things like at Brown
University they're there they're
storming into the Provost of Provost's
office and saying please exempt us from
traditional college expectations like
going to class or studying or doing well
on our exams because as students of
color at Brown we have to work so hard
at staying alive on this campus this is
a delusion no Brown student of any
racial or ethnic group
is at risk of his life from circum
ambient racism and yet the diversity
bureaucracy is a enthusiastic audience
to that sort of delusional tantrum and
encourages it in students and they are
bringing that mentality with them into
the world at large that is so
fascinating the diversity delusion the
diversity bureaucracy and it's affecting
so many if not all Western college
campuses is it been it's become pretty
much all now yes you can't find it it's
not something confined to say the Ivy
League's it's not confined to small
private schools it's in community
colleges it's in large state schools
it's in small state schools the
humanities have largely been wrecked by
the expectation that arose in the 1980s
that as a college student you should not
be expected to read the alleged what the
Western canon
you you have the growth of this
ridiculously ignorant phrase of dead
white males students are being taught to
feel contempt for the greatest works of
Western civilization on the basis of the
skin color and gonads of their authors
something that is completely irrelevant
students are rejecting these works with
the encouragement of their professors
having never read them but it is this
victimology that is leading to the
assaults on free speech that we've seen
take over campuses over the last couple
of years because the students again
claim that they are being victimized so
much on campus and that non-orthodox
political views that reject this racial
victimology puts them at lethal risk
anything that is non-orthodox is a form
of hate speech and that therefore they
have a right to silence it with violence
if necessary and this is exactly where I
want to go lead into just free speech
the idea that the diversity bureaucracy
is making it difficult for people to
critique the diversity bureaucracy with
the rioting and the protesting that we
are so privileged to live in today's
time with the resources that we have and
to ride in protest to such an extent
where we can't have an economist
conversation with the other person
across the table about our ideas and
about where we should build a future
towards this that's very unsettling for
me because we really need to be able to
have civilized discourse about where we
should go in the future looking forward
to the diversity delusion maybe any last
thoughts Heather on on kind of how we
can have more of this civilized
discourse what are these steps that we
have to take in order to be able to get
back at that
well the predominant part has been to
issue rousing peons to free speech and
reasoned discourse and that is of course
important because you have two
alternatives you can have discourse and
and civil argumentation or you have
force and violence the idea of resolving
disagreement and conflict through
persuasion and rhetoric is one of the
great advances of our civilization and
it is it is not trivial to see the
increasing normalization and indeed
celebration of the use of force to shut
down opposing viewpoints after the
February riots against Milo you not
last year in Berkeley there were two
Berkeley professors who sent out emails
to their fellow faculty basically
congratulating the empty five thugs for
shutting down the Milo talk so you have
this is being normalized now but I would
argue that however important it is to
try and educate people about the massive
advance and importance of civil
discourse college presidents can come
out with every you know petition they
want or statement of principles and very
few of them are doing so but even if
everyone would it wouldn't matter as
long as we have this ideology of
victimhood that is being so relentlessly
promoted by colleges because it is that
ultimately which is driving the assaults
on free speech and as long as people are
being brainwashed into thinking
themselves as victims when they are
occupying the most well endowed Pacific
environments in human history you're
going to continue to see these demands
to shut down the speech yes exactly
persuasion and rhetoric is such an
advancement of human cognitive ability
and it's one of the main foundations of
advancing civilization this quantum of
rhetoric and persuasion and victimhood
has definitely become the main sort of
essence of wanting to proclaim that oh
something so wrong it's so wrong rather
than picking a part of the world on your
back and going out forth and trying to
make things better in some way making
some value into the world and you know
and all that good stuff that has kind of
been discussed by you and a lot of
people
the intellectual darkweb it's very
interesting Heather maybe a quick
question for you about let's maybe
mention the cosmos do you think that
we're alone in the cosmos Heather well I
don't know about alien forms of life I
would say probably given the age of the
cosmos and its massive size and the
result of a constant evolution change
that it would be unusual if we were the
only life form in the universe and
Heather what do you think is the purpose
of life to make human meaning I am I
think to try to strive to express
yourself to help others to a certain
extent but to try to contribute what you
can to your own advancement into that of
others I would say itself something of
gratitude for the extraordinary
scientific technological advances and
artistic wealth that is at our
fingertips today yeah make the best
meaning we can for ourselves for others
and be grateful for the world that a
hundred plus billion people have built
this beautiful world we live in today so
Heather McDonald what an absolute
pleasure I'm so grateful that we're able
to make the Skype happen from New York
we're gonna put links in the bottom for
the war on cops your your book as well
as your upcoming book diversity delusion
hopefully released in the fall
you have an op-ed that you just wrote so
we'll put a link down there in the
footer as well and the bio I really hope
to have you in San Francisco soon stop
by the studio we'll do some more great
conversation and thank you so much
Heather thank you so much is being at
your service this girl never seems to be
able to solve but anyway great thank you
I appreciate it
is it agree we still have some people in
San Francisco at least having the
civilized discourse with both sides we
got to have that and even in the Midwest
of the u.s. words potentially very
conservative it's important to be able
to have discourse across the table you
everyone for tuning in and we'll talk
more soon see ya